-We are in the Doombox.
Our next three songs
will decide tonight's champions.
It's time for "Slay It,
Don't Spray It."
♪ Better know the words,
or you get sprayed ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, here's how this works. On
your turn, you'll have to sing
a well-known song,
karaoke style.
You'll have the lyrics
in front of you.
But when the music drops out,
you have to finish
the line from memory.
If you don't get
the lyrics exactly right,
those microphones will spray you
and your partner
in the face with water.
But if you can slay it
and sing all the words
perfectly,
then your opponents
get drenched instead.
Each song is worth
50,000 points.
Alright, Keke and Saweetie,
your team is up first.
Let's see what song you get.
[ Beeping ]
"Wrecking Ball" by Miley Cyrus.
Now you have to decide
who knows "Wrecking Ball" more.
-Don't none of us
know this song.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, okay, I know some --
I know enough --
-I know the chorus.
-So you want
paper, scissors, rock?
-Girl.
-Rock, paper, scissors?
-The voice should do it.
You are the voice.
-Oh, God.
-Know that's right.
-Pressure's on, Keke.
Here we go. Get ready!
-I ain't gon' win this. Okay.
-Feeling confident?
Still good. Yeah!
-♪ All you ever did was
wreck me ♪
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Babe, I know
that's right, girl!
-I'm sorry, bud.
Yo!
Not only did you crush it,
but "wre-e-e-ck me"!
You nailed it! Oh, wow.
You nailed it,
nailed it, nailed it.
Whoo! That is 50,000 points
for your team.
Let's see what happened
to you guys in slow-motion.
Oh, that's not fair. Oh.
[ Slow-motion groan ]
Okay, Will.i.am, Joel,
it is your turn.
Let's see what song
you guys get.
[ Beeping ]
Willie Nelson,
"On the Road Again."
Which one of you guys
knows this song well?
-I got water
all in my face, so...
-So you're going
to give it to Joel?
-I'm going to go with Keke.
Go ahead.
-No, no, no, no, no.
That's not the way this works.
-She's great.
Did you see earlier?
-That's not the way this works.
That's not the way this works.
Joel, I think we're just gonna
say you're gonna do this one.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You go, you go, Joel.
-Joel McHale singing "On the
Road Again" by Willie Nelson.
-I'm taking these off.
-Here we go, bud.
-I love Joel.
♪♪
-Pretty good.
Will, are you ready to get wet?
Why are you --
-Know that's right.
-Don't want to get wet.
-♪ And then a bunch of other
stuff happens in this song ♪
♪ But these aren't the lyrics ♪
-[ Laughing ]
You got to stay in.
Get back in there. Come on.
-Damn, they really
getting soaked.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
-Your guess was the line,
"A bunch of other things happen
in this song."
-♪ And a bunch of other things
happen in this song he wrote ♪
So did I get it?
-No.
Look at you guys.
Supermodels, supermodels.
The correct lyrics were,
"Insisting that the world
keep turning our way."
That 50,000 points
for Keke and Saweetie.
Let's see that in slow-motion.
Watch Will go --
Yeah, there you go. Yeah.
Oh, my gosh. That's rough.
Alright, everybody. It is time
for the final round.
And we're really going to raise
the stakes on this one.
Watch your heads, because
we got the big mics
coming in right now.
Look at this.
-[ Deep voice ]
The game's about to get better,
'cause you're about
to get wetter.
-This is so sad.
-Alright, now, all four of you
are going to take turns singing,
so pay attention to your screen.
You're going to switch off
line by line.
When the music stops,
you have to nail the lyrics,
or you and your partner
will get drenched.
And this round
is worth 200,000 points.
Whoever wins this
wins the whole thing.
Let's see what
our final song is tonight.
[ Beeping ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Celebration," Kool & the Gang.
You know that one.
Everyone knows that one.
-Yeah.
-♪ Celebrate good times ♪
-♪ Come on ♪
-Yeah, that's it.
-Yeah.
I'm not getting in there,
though.
Okay, here we go.
Will, you're going
to start us off, Will.i.am.
Here we go.
♪♪
-Whoo-hoo! Oh, shucks.
♪ Right here ♪
-That's right.
Joel, you're up.
Yeah!
Keke.
Will.
Saweetie.
Joel.
-We're gonna have a good time.
-♪ Time to come together ♪
-♪ To come together ♪
-Keke.
-♪ It's not the lyrics I know ♪
Please don't get my hair.
I'm not playing with y'all!
[ Laughter ]
-What the --
Oh, my God. Saweetie.
What? You fell apart.
[ Laughter ]
[ Slow-motion laughing ]
-Did we just win?!
-You guys just won
"That's My Jam."
-Oh, hell naw.
-Wow.
-That's for you, bud.
-Oh, my God. [ Laughs ]
You won. That's the way
the game works.
-Yeah. Yeah, bro,
bump that. Bump that.
-Oh. Oh, my God. Jimmy,
this is so much heavier.
-No, no.
-So much heavier
than I expected.
-The whole system is rigged.
-The whole system --
We got to -- We got to talk.
We'll talk during the --
during the credits.